hey guys today we have the first
installment of our string theory lecture
series my guest today is Andy Morgan
he's my friend from originally
Birmingham England and now of Sakha
Japan he's a great diet coach and we're
delighted to have him own this is this
is quite a long interview just you know
what you're getting yourself in for but
we think you'll enjoy it he's a he has a
lot of good stories to tell a lot of
great insights about the coaching
process and if you stick around until
the end we will have an outtake reel of
all of the stuff that is not too
inappropriate to put on YouTube so
thanks for watching
and without further ado let's get into
it hey guys welcome to the first
installment of our string theory
interview series my guest today is Andy
Morgan and this episode is brought to
you by the 'let rap quadruple the
regular one is absolutely fantastic this
is a barrel-aged quad just brings out
some more complexity in the beer will
get you equally wasted as the original
while also making you feel slightly
classier while you're doing it and also
empty your wallet pretty quickly because
this bottle here was how much it's like
20 bucks yeah Lindsay's behind the
camera she just she just gave gave me a
face didn't know that it was 20 bucks
yeah well we live in North Carolina
where cost of living is pretty low so we
spend money on beer and toys for Oswald
and that's about it
anyway spend money on the things you
love problem probably beer most of the
time all right so this is Andy Morgan
like I said he is visiting from Osaka
Japan originally from Birmingham England
not Birmingham
that's Alabama and he runs a to fitness
websites ripped body
JP and
we buddy JP ripped body is the English
language version and athlete's body is
the Japanese one so for most people
watching this probably go to ripped body
unless you are bilingual but seen as
most of my audiences American it's like
2% of you uh so Andy tell us a little
bit about yourself how did you get into
fitness
initially okay so it started you still
you still have some in your cup even oh
this is uh this is a prop right so it's
started and are we going all the way
back here we're going as far back as you
want to all right so I'm 15 years old
I've just come out of a cinema which
means movie theater for you guys and I'm
standing outside just three my friends
there's three girls and we're waiting
for the bus home and the 107 bus comes
down the road stops and a gang of 20 to
30 kids piles off now about one or two
years older I'm figuring there might be
drunk or drugged up or something because
this is a double-decker bus and one of
them he jumps out the back window
anyway they barrel across the street and
it's okay to talk about yeah they're
barrel across the street decided to
start a fight one and takes a bottle
tries to smash me on the head I block it
now instead of thinking that there might
be another one cutting this is my pro
tip I went out and then I got slammed
with that glass bottle back yeah
which when I go bald you're gonna see my
nice scar there and and yes I had a
cracks go on that that basically led me
to get into karate so that hopefully I
could get over my fear of being in my in
my own hometown
unfortunately my god it took about three
years but there you go so I got into
karate then I went to university and I
still doing karate and
then I graduated I was studying
economics and Finance I went to bum
University and everyone was getting
these really boring dull jobs in banking
and finance and I was just kind of there
in November and everyone was applying
and I was thinking oh yeah [ __ ] this I
was thinking you know like I'm not ready
for this yet so I just finished the
biography and this guy he went over to
Japan he was teaching English he decided
to do this crazy Aikido course um with
the riot police have to take if they
were which people have to take if they
want to be able to be a riot copy in
Japan and they basically brutalized for
an entire year and I thought wow that
sounds amazing
let's go to Japan and do karate so I'm
looking for in the station job so I've
got any excuse to go to Japan and not
get a proper boring banking job like I
thought I had to go over to Japan did
the karate get into the Aikido this
isn't making any sense right it's making
sense ok so again you you you got your
ass kicked
yeah you wanted to not get your ass
kicked yep you liked learning how to
kick people's asses and not get your ass
kicked
hmm so you decided to take it to Japan
to step it up a notch because you also
wanted to avoid getting your ass kicked
by just the the soul-sucking sadness of
the business world something like that
good work could you actually sit back a
little and look thank you I can look a
little a little bigger that's the
Gregor's just we can what's the word
inferior he's gonna go for emasculated
and emasculated
right so I'm in Japan now I'm doing
karate I'm doing Aikido and in karate
quite a week Aikido five to six seven
sessions a week I'm trying to turn
myself into Jason Bourne
and I'm also trying to hit the gym at
the same time and I've been hitting the
gym since I well since about two years
after I got bottled because I realized
that being being is a good self-defense
because no one wants to pick on you but
uh I just failed miserably and I stayed
skinny but this didn't really hit home
and I was screwing around and not really
getting anywhere until I'm on the beach
in go up that's in India visiting a
friend and this girl we get into a
conversation and she says hey you really
don't look like you work out as much as
you do and obviously that that's like a
swift kick in the nuts yeah but it kind
of woke me up the reality of the
situation I'm not very big wasn't very
ripped and I just didn't look very good
and then that got me thinking about why
that was and then that got me thinking
about proper training and nutrition so
that's how I got into the that's kind of
that was kind of my gateway into this
all right yeah so Andy what does a
typical day in the life of Andy Morgan
look like what what does Andy Morgan do
so that talked to you about the how I
why I'm doing the gentleman Barry yeah
okay so where did I get you
yeah okay so after that comment on the
beach edge on the bottle and chipping
osaka' everyone's getting just ripped
all ripped for summer and it's no
mystery to them why but it's a mystery
to me so I start asking them questions I
start copying their training
I'm going down the gym six days a week
I'm doing my cardio as well I'm buying
$200 worth of supplements from
bodybuilding.com and I'm eating six
meals a day and you know yeah I got I
got shredded and but I felt like I was
on a food hunt the inspire time and I
was scared to go and we've had I think
my I was gonna go at the house for more
than three hours I had to have my
protein shake what's up yeah with me and
then did you in Japan at the time like
where the fanny pack still in or did you
have a murse or was it like in a cooler
so I could you look like a dad going
like a t-ball game I had a fanny pack
I'm just picturing this right okay so
one of the teachers at my school was
working at high school I had a I had if
he bought it for me and it's very sorry
you said I used to have a sports bike
until I got the band and then sold it so
that was very useful for having it on
your back I'm just a be fine and
stuffing because I realized that having
your phone stuck on your tank and trying
to read the GPS just this nature gotcha
okay
you know those barrels that you have my
way anyway
so yeah I used to keep my protein shake
in there and then I was in the gym one
day and a friend of mine Steve he comes
up to me and I haven't seen him in a few
months and he goes and he like shows me
his abs and he must have lost about 20
25 pounds I'm like what and he's like
yeah and I've been eating pizza pretty
much every day this just like the last
30 seconds of what you said sounded like
the start of a Mike Chang ad so so Andy
tell us your secrets to getting shredded
every day while you eating pizza so the
warm simple trick
shredded is click this link at the
bottom of the video right well while we
eat our sushi with forks and and and hit
some find women at the pool with a beach
ball have you seen that one you're not a
fine purveyor of Mike Chang ads but
admire them at the same time yeah so you
heard it here first Andy Morgan admires
Mike Chang and so his buddy Steve that's
that's his Mike Chang [ __ ] all right so
so Japanese Mike change let's uh dude
let's hear how you do this thank you
know that Mike's probably gonna take
this segment he's gonna put it in one of
these videos and then scream you're like
Greg knuckles of strength every common
Andy Morgan everybody about JP support I
mean he doesn't care what we think he's
the number one most subscribed trainer
on YouTube we're just we're just a
little peons in the Mike chain universe
it's quite true that is true
so my mate Steve he says to me go to
lean Gamescom and have a read and I read
and I read the whole thing back to back
and this puts me in a rage cuz I've been
spending a lot of money that I don't
really have they could have been spent
on better things on all these
supplements and I've been on a food hunt
now for a year and a half eating six
meals a day and this guide Martin Burton
says that I can eat two or three meals a
day and still get the same results and
train three four days a week and still
get the same results and I try it still
the results are the same and I'm just
infuriated and I decide right I have to
tell everybody in Japan about it and I
start a blog writing it in English and
in Japanese and I tried to rescue in
Japan from itself because the fitness
industry there is really brought the
Wild West because you don't have many
people much
like the American film which is in no
way like the wife s well right imagine
that one steroids
most of the American fitness industry is
also on steroids that's true just a very
bad form of that because there's no
there's no checks and balances the
difference with Japan is if you're
Japanese you don't speak English because
there just don't speak English and so
you can't go out there and check if
someone's trying to sell you on a 7-day
apple juice fast you can't go out there
and just the check for the [ __ ]
because there's no one else who really
talked about it
you can if you speak English so I wanted
to be the counterbalance for that so
we've worked really hard over the last
four years we've built up the Japanese
website so it's now the biggest Fitness
site in Japan that's actually quite a JP
finally people are starting to hire us
you said you said you saw the the Miss
Universe competitor for Japan wearing
one of your t-shirts right oh no that
was us miss Japan
mr. okay mrs. Japan mrs. Jimmy yeah
she's got Jim receptions okay yeah she's
cool yeah I gave that each other
john-boy okay
I I thought that was a cool story it's
it's just a kind of cool story yeah it's
sorry sorry sorry about that yeah so
yeah there you go so what I do is I put
out two fitness information websites I
hope guys just simplify how to get
ripped
I kind of hate that phrase now and but
that's like your entire brand rip what
it would be like if I said I hated
people getting strings heavy screwed no
I just I prefer the word shredded yeah
rolls off the tongue
you can just set up redirects so
everything goes to shredded body budget
so yet and people hide me to be one one
email consultations for 12 weeks to
coach them to set up that day and they
training okay so about that something
something that I think a lot of people
will be confused about when you say you
you coach people for 12 weeks is usually
a plan that says I will coach you for
this many weeks most of them make just
kind of outlandish promises you know
where where you say basically like no
matter how big you are like I'll get you
shredded in this period of time or
you'll lose X amount of weight in this
period of time hmm but but you do that
quite a bit differently how how do you
set it up and why is it only twelve
weeks why don't you take on people from
up here yeah okay um so twelve weeks is
a good time frame to get someone bought
in that's something that people can
commit to anything well it's just a good
balance you need anything longer and
it's kind of pushing what people believe
that they can commit to and anything
less and you might struggle to get the
ball rolling for them so they start
seeing results and really I want to
leave people in the position where
they've started to see results and they
feel that they're happy they feel
comfortable they know what they're doing
and they know how to move forward and
and do it on their own so 12 weeks is a
good time frame for that so let's say I
took you I made an estimate that your
calorie expenditure and your macros and
your training obviously you know what
you're doing so I need to talk about
that and I mess it up and for the first
four weeks I always wait for four weeks
you're not losing weight for some reason
and then I have to find you right if our
plan is only six weeks
then you're not gonna be happy yeah
right but I think it's essential that we
have firstly four weeks to gauge how
things are going before they're making
any adjustments are looking at the data
and seeing how things of them so that
would be weight and measurements and
liftings does so twelve weeks is good
for and and so so basically your goal is
at the at the end of 12 weeks you want
people to not need you anymore right
yeah yeah not not trying to create like
long-term dependence essentially yeah um
so that's one of the things I get a lot
of coaching applicants so I'm very
fortunate in that and you know like I
love what I do and I'm very appreciative
of the people that share my website that
enable me to keep doing what I do and
what I've been able to do is essentially
say look I can't promise you results but
we'll do our best to get them I think
anyone that promises results they either
haven't been in the industry long enough
or they just they don't care well in it
I think I think one thing that a lot of
coaches are confused about is because I
know I know people who I know their
hearts in the right place that still
promise results and I think what that
kind of comes from is a belief that like
you as the coach can make the results
happen but I mean at the end of the day
it's the client who has to put in the
work like they have to follow the diet
they have to follow the training program
so like your job as a coaches is to to
give them the advice and put them in the
right direction for success but
ultimately you can't promise results
because you I mean you're working with
adults you you can't force them to do
what you tell them to right hey guys
welcome back to part two of my interview
with Amy Morgan if you've forgotten
already
and
is the purveyor of to fine fitness
websites roof repair brick body JP an
athlete's body JP they're both
absolutely fantastic he wound up in
Japan because he took up karate because
he didn't want to get his ass kicked
anymore
and so now he is busy kicking asses in
the Japanese fitness industry and
getting people shredded the easy way
this second part of the interview is
brought to you by old stock ale it's
quite good but not as good as billa trap
that was the sponsor by sponsor I mean
and II bought it of the first part of
this interview all right
so rolling right along Andy you've
coached a lot of people well first of
all just how many people have you
coached in the past what four years
let's say over a thousand over a
thousand over a thousand that sounds
like a ridiculous number but I work
online and I work in the email only and
I've heard some very long hours but to
me it was very addictive because I could
get an insane amount of experience in a
relatively short amount of time and it
was I just find the work very very
rewarding so you know every day you're
learning something new and every day you
see ways that you can improve your
methods the way that you coach people
and just yeah man it's just been really
good so yeah that's a lot of people but
yeah it's just turned me into a bit of a
data monster especially when it comes to
like tracking people's progress just
what to look forward to see if they've
if they've actually genuinely still
than they need to start reducing their
calories or increasing their calories
and of course macros come on that but
you know not sure where they need to
actually make a reduction or an increase
to keep on cutting or bulk or whether
it's just a stall whether it's just the
fact that their body's playing tricks on
them and maybe their fat cells are
filling with water as the fat is
emptying ahead of them and we just need
to wait that kind of messes with
people's heads and I kind of helped my
and then we established that you can
that you can swear in these interviews
yeah I don't know I just think it's
unprofessional
plus my mom wouldn't like it and my dad
will probably wash it in the living room
and that means that my mom will be sat
across from the living room reading a
book and she'll probably be hearing this
my mom all right fair enough
so you've coached a lot of people I
think I think a lot of people are
confused about what you're actually
paying for in a coach they think that
the the main things that coach brings to
the table is it's almost like they have
some sort of magic training program or
magic diet which we both know it's not
the case at all so so what what are
people really paying for when they hire
coach it's funny when you say no magic
information did you is that because you
read my edit today of the coaching page
oh no no okay
so I've made my 200 and what was it
Lynn's 254 yeah yeah I made my 254 edit
to my coaching page today that's the
page where people can apply to work with
me yeah um I'm another write but I wrote
that specifically today look I don't
have any secrets I don't have any magic
or to help people do is to apply the
principles that I write about on
website and that's what we do we talk
about we talk about the principles that
we apply with our clients helping guide
people on our website on our websites
yeah
so really this the drawing any secrets
it's all just out there and it's all
there for you to go out read and apply
for yourself so why would you why would
you hire a coach man this sounds like a
sales pitch now it's written up I'm not
even coaching at the moment okay and
you're not either right and that that
currently many not any new clients Yeah
right okay so so there you go it's not a
sales pitch since since people aren't
paying for any sort of like magic pixie
dust what are people actually getting
when they pay for a coach accountability
objectivity and buy-in so you know I
know every coach at there knows that
it's pretty much impossible to work with
your siblings your parents or any of
your friends it's because they even
though they want to respect what you say
the information that you're gonna give
them is free and when something's free
you don't respect it you don't act on it
you don't implement it so doesn't mean
as much to you now if I say to you I
want you to pay the cost of an Xbox a
couple of controllers and ten games all
of a sudden you're now going to take
this a lot more seriously because you
are brought in to the process you don't
want to feel that you've wasted that
money so what I tell you now and carries
far more weight and you're far more
likely to act on it well you will act on
it I mean that's one thing I do I think
you probably do too if I get the
impression that someone's not going to
act on their information
they give them and I just don't take
them on as a client there's a one-finger
because it's a waste of our time and
their money yeah I mean like my business
your business yeah it's it's a word of
math I don't have any habits like if I'm
gonna work with someone who's not gonna
be successful that means I'm taking not
taking on someone who could be
successful and that person who could be
successful I mean I don't know who
they're gonna be um like this guy at the
minimum is gonna be walking around
feeling good looking great being just
this referral machine for me and people
are gonna ask him how he did it they're
gonna say yep I read this website ended
up hiring the guy but the information is
really good you don't have to hire the
guy and it's like what 99.9% of the
people that come to the site they just
go there they get the information they
go away and they're successful and some
of them sent me a message and I say
thank you very much and that means a lot
right
but that not point one percent they
apply some of them end up being clients
and that keeps me in clean undies and
expensive beers it's a win-win okay yeah
I lost my chain of thought so so that
was buying that was buying yeah
objectivity and accountability um okay
so objectivity so you can read what's on
our websites and you can decide okay I
I'm pretty sure this is for me but
there's a high value in in one of us
saying that yes that is for you that's
what I want you to do just that mental
switch in mindset is just going to make
you do better
also when you're dieting down especially
when you're taking people from not from
like 25 to 20 or 20 to 15 but like let's
say 12 to September 7 body fat
especially when you get sub 10 percent
body fat people start second-guessing
everything they're doing just because
you have to take things very slowly so
that they don't lose muscle so I mean at
the lower end of this you're talking
like half a pound of fat a week people
can drive this off completely nuts when
they get like a water weight fluctuation
no they said it's some particularly
salty food right they can just
completely lose their [ __ ] and their the
first thing they want to do is make a
reduction in their calorie or macro
intake right and one here to save them
from doing that because you want them at
the end of their diet to be eating as
much as they possibly can so that their
mood is high their libido is high their
training is not on point their training
as hard as they can so they're not
losing any muscle mass so yeah we helped
take the that mental game out of it for
them those mind games that happen when
you diet down and again when you when
you're bulking as well that's another
big thing you just you just here to you
know people I hope them
it's normal it's normal am i is what I'm
experiencing normal so many people they
just want to say yeah that is yeah it's
absolutely normal in in it's not just
diet - it's also a training yeah people
have one bad workout or one bad week of
workouts oh and and I mean people people
can have bad days at any point for for
literally any reason Under the Sun a bad
week more often than not they'll be like
my numbers were way down this week
didn't have very much energy and the
first thing I'll ask it's like well was
there some sort of aberration in your
life like were you not sleeping as much
did you have a deadline at work and I
mean almost every time they'll come back
with like oh yeah like I had I had
something going on in my life like I had
some sort of family emergency I had a
big deadline I was only sleeping five
hours a night my health there's nothing
wrong with the trainee program then and
there's nothing wrong with you I mean
that that stuff definitely comes first
and if your training takes that hit
because of it I mean that's life but
then the next week as soon as you can
get back on the wagon I mean things are
fine there's not an issue with the plan
and the only time that you would really
need to make an adjustment in that
situation is if say there were you know
like a month or two of stuff like that
with really no end in sight but I mean
yeah just life happens and a lot of
people are way too quick to just
completely scrap a plan or make big
changes just because they had a bad week
or even a bad day and one of the biggest
things I do as a coach is just be like
no things are working
you have 12 solid weeks of training
behind you this was just the one outlier
like just just keep forging ahead and
the nine times out of ten like as soon
as their schedule gets back to normal
things are fine absolutely yeah yeah
accountability that was the third point
we had noted down
it's I won't make I insist that my
clients they check in with me that's
what they've paid for so they're either
checking in every two weeks or four
weeks depending on what level of contact
their choose right and if they don't
check in you know I'm not gonna be hard
on them but they know that they fight
they know that my time is limited they
know that they've hired me and so
they're one of my clients I want them to
do well so they know they feel I want
them to feel in a way that they owe it
to me to get their [ __ ] on point so that
when they are out with their friends and
they can have that doughnut or that that
box of donuts that's been passed around
the office and is really tempting it's
just the case of making it a little
making them think twice that's it yeah
Frank
it's just weird to make them think twice
about doing yeah yeah sure unless you
wake up you're feeling pretty tired it's
like no no get down the gym because they
know that at that checkpoint they're
gonna have to say yeah yeah so I missed
a couple of workouts and went over the
macros here okay what is it was a
wedding was it like a bachelor party was
it again no like Tracy she came into the
office and she had Krispy Kremes you
know passed an amount because it was
Kev's birthday and you know I didn't
want to yeah you know then yeah it's not
a problem you eat one but you know the
one is 6 and then lieutenant
I don't know whenever I don't think I've
never accidentally I have definitely
even 12 doughnuts in a city in Philly it
was never like an absent-minded things
it was it was more of like a you know
I'm 14 years old and my friends are like
I bet she can't eat 12 doughnuts and
then I
that was a mistake yeah yeah now fair
enough but I can't ability again that's
a big factor there's one more point that
I'd like to say and that is like why
would someone hire a coach you can hire
someone because you believe in them and
because you believe in them that's going
to make you believe in you and belief is
everything was your video was it called
mental barriers yeah yeah brilliant
video Greg's video mental barriers only
get in the description yeah okay yeah
you've also got the the article that
goes with that but I do will note that
in the description
like mindset is huge welcome back to the
third part of the string theory
interview with Annie Morgan third part
this interview is brought to you by
really old brown dog from Smuttynose
Andy you are you're quite the world
traveler you you currently live in Osaka
Japan yes but you've traveled all around
the place or all around the globe even
hmm and you've managed to stay in good
shape and stay shredded the whole time
how how do you manage to pull this off
okay so like I think a big mistake that
people make is they get into the 100% or
0% mindset a black and white mindset but
they're either on the program and
they're doing it or they're completely
off so a good example of this will be
people this is especially true of
dieters especially neurotic dieters and
that's one thing I try and fish out
before taking my Nonna's clients
honestly I still want the hassle people
that have eating disorders is just it's
not professional for me to take them on
it's not my field
yeah I would just way outside your scope
of expertise absolutely
it wouldn't ya so people that they'll go
out with their friends and they'll be
like ah I'm at I can't cook I therefore
it's a cheap meal three of these umami
burgers excellent by the way Thank You
Chad Landers aka Iron Man yes um
then that pan down ten beers then and
I've cheesecake afterwards those shakes
that we had last night
Oh cookout okay look out good moon if
you're from the American South you know
the sweet nectar that we that we speak
of if not if you're ever in North
Carolina and you drive by a somewhat
shady looking drive-thru burger
establishment car cookout you have to go
by you have like forty three flavors of
milkshakes they're absolutely delicious
that's the point
way way overboard though like the only
size they come in is like there's like
sixteen ounces of just pure decadence
alright so split it with like eight
friends yes do that so back to the point
people are either like I'm on or off and
when they're off people tend to go to
severely overboard and I think part of
that comes down to people diet generally
too hard for too long and that leads
them into these binge cycles but if you
take things slowly again which can be
mentally tough which is why you might
hire someone to make you take you slowly
then you don't when you go out you're
not like it's a free meal but it's not a
free meal because it's eight thousand
calories now that you've just pounded
down so then you have to check in with
your coach and be like hey it was good
for 13 of the last 14 days and then one
day I eat 12,000 calories and then one
day I went off plan for one meal and I'm
like hmm
you're 5 pounds heavier now it's like
what constipation it could be that yeah
it could be that you had a random salty
meal but it's probably that that one in
14 meal let me ask a little bit more
about this right but to answer your
question when you're traveling just
don't get into that one off mindset you
can still get your portions you can
still eyeball don't be afraid to leave
stuff on the plate when you would read
obviously if you're a grandma this has
be polite eat whatever the hell she puts
in front of you
but when you're eating out of
restaurants you don't have to eat
everything just because it's on the
plate you can take a bag of protein with
you which can lead to interesting
exchanges with the TSA quicker with
customs in different countries but the
other day it's just brighten right so
put that in a bag and take it with you
yeah and if it comes to it you can do
some workouts either in a really crappy
hotel gym or even in your hotel room it
just requires a bit of dedication right
let's just get up you can do bodyweight
squats you try some pistol squats
push-ups go outside Chin's on a branch
in the park I mean you get the point
right it doesn't have to be 100% or 0%
and that I think is the biggest problem
for people another thing if you decided
to take time off of training let's say
you wanted to go travel for a month to
three and you decided that actually
you're not gonna do anything it's not
that you have to go
it's just screw it I'm not gonna do
anything you're not going to suddenly
lose all of your gains all of your
training for the past few years isn't
all going to go to [ __ ]
great it's one of one of my favorite
posts on great site is just freaking you
you're talking about my nuclear gave me
my nuclear domain theory
please like so the basic idea the
between behind a my nuclear domain
theory is that basically as as your
muscles hypertrophy as they get bigger
the muscle fibers themselves are getting
bigger and muscle fibers are single
cells but they have multiple nuclei
called nuclei and the kind of goo inside
the muscles called the sarcoplasm each
nucleus can only kind of oversee a
certain volume of that sarcoplasm and so
as your muscle fibers grow you have
these things called satellite cells that
hang out around your muscle fibers and
you have to fuse more satellite cells
onto your muscle fibers for them to
continue to grow as that as the total
volume of that sarcoplasm expands and so
what happens is as you as your muscles
atrophy and we're not talking about like
on the scale of decades here we're
talking on the scale get smaller yeah
yeah you're you get less swoll we're
talking about the scale of you know like
weeks or months you you lose volume in
the muscle fibers themselves you have
less sarcoplasm you have fewer
myofibrils just the stuff inside the
muscle fiber but you hang on to the vast
vast majority of those my nuclei and
that's one of the rate limiting steps of
muscles getting bigger in the first
place so you stop training your muscles
get smaller and then if anyone's taken
up her long layoff you you know how this
works within you know within a couple
weeks say maybe 70 80 percent of your
strength comes back within a month or
two tops even if you took six months out
of the gym yeah all of your string
back and it's time to make new gains and
the reason for that is that it's a lot
easier to Rhea cumulate the the protein
and the sarcoplasm and just all of the
other stuff making the muscle fibers big
as long as you still have those maile
nuclei there to oversee the growth
basically and so you know like Andy was
saying even if you have to take or just
want to take I mean life is great just
just live a little
live a little I spent far too many years
of my life sorry to take everybody
memories of my life worrying about this
stuff I wish I just taken this yo pill
on many occasions and just enjoyed
another one if you're if you're 80% is
big 80% is lean but twice as happy I
mean that's a that's a net gain but yeah
so I mean if you have to take a month or
two off for injury or you know because
you're going somewhere that doesn't have
a gym or if you just want to take a
month or two up is you having time with
family yeah if you're going to look
after a loved one it's gonna happen to
all of us I mean hell it doesn't
yeah don't don't put important [ __ ] in
your life on hold because you want to
keep your gains brah
anyway so if something if something like
that happens really like like you will
get smaller you will lose muscle you
will lose strength a little bit a little
bit yeah
and it scales with how long it is if
it's a week or two don't even worry
about that if it's months yeah you'll
lose a fair amount of muscle inch
strength but you hold on to the vast
vast majority of those my own nuclei and
so when you start training again all of
that progress you made previously will
come back really really fast so just
just chill out a little bit um and if
you can't get in perfect training when
you're vacationing when you're on the
road or just like if you just want to
enjoy yourself and just something that
helps out a lot of people is like
training starts becoming stressful to
them they get so called it caught up in
what their
and their goals and they're just
constantly grinding towards that that
they that they carry on your silly my
beers that they develop in a adversive
relationship with the process of
training and they kind of lose some of
that fire and some of that hunger so for
some people just taking like a couple
weeks or up to a month off can be the
best thing for you possible it just
makes you excited to get back in the gym
again or my excitement then leads to
better workout yes it's all about
playing the wonking and if that means
living your life a little bit and losing
some gains in the short run that's
really not an issue because they'll come
back quickly and you'll be mentally
refreshed when you do come back to it
all right
so Andy moving on to our next topic you
you've got a lot of your initial
audience and notoriety from bringing
lean gain style intermittent fasting to
Japan what is your current tape on
intermittent fasting actually what
happened was I didn't bring in the men
fasting to Japan well I did now like
four years later but I got what happened
was this I was in Japan I was thoroughly
pissed off with the horrible bro myths
that I believed which led me on to a
food hunt for years I mean eating six
meals a day and I was upset and I
decided to blog about it and I emailed
Martin Birkin and asked him if I could
write about his methods in Japanese if I
could translate someone who's working to
Japanese and he said yes and he was very
very kind very nice about it
you know absolutely just make sure you
do a good job so we did a good job
nobody cared
but people cared about my English
language stuff and what's the question
again once you get her in like but I
can't take the management in fasting so
it's like people cared about my English
language stuff and then people started
coming to me and saying how much do you
charge for online coaching and
consultations and Here I am and I'm
thinking wow I I was thinking of going
like going at the loan and trying to
market myself as a one-on-one trainer to
richer folks you know using the fact
that I'm a white guy in Japan my English
language ability potentially puts me
ahead of the average Japanese trainer
because of the information I have access
to and here are people they're trying to
hire me they want to pay me without
actually meeting them and they're happy
I'm happy
very nice win-win there so I start up I
start talking about any instrument
fasting I start talking about Martin's
methods the two to four maybe four
articles and then people start hiring me
through that so what it said to Martin
at that time and this probably not very
interesting to you guys but to me it's
very important in terms of integrity I
said to mine look I want to make you
famous in Japan I want to help
absolutely crush these myths in Japan
and on that premise I said can I
translate your work and he was like yes
absolutely go for it and he was very
supportive and I just didn't let up so
even though nobody cared on the Japanese
side of things for years
I just wanted to push that ahead and now
finally people like Martin barkins
leaned Games's is like Martin if he goes
to Japan like people in the industry
they'll know his name but it took a long
time to get there
you know so yeah I forgot my the
question was what is he saying what what
is my current acronym but but he said
before that like with my advice oh yeah
yes I met yeah pushing it forward in
Japan so that that's why I when when I
say I'm gonna do something I'll follow
the hell through with it I followed the
hell through with that my current
sacramentum in the fasting is pretty
much this it is a very convenient and
easy way of setting up your your diet
there are different forms of in a minute
fasting you the one that I recommend to
a lot of clients not all is to skip
breakfast eat lunch eat dinner there you
go obviously depending but for a lot of
people eat lunch eat dinner what this
does is it helps people control their
hunger in the mornings it gives people
the chance to still eat fairly large
meals despite the fact that they're
reducing overall calorie intake so it
has benefits in terms of hunger for
Liza and like for the dieter their
biggest enemy is hungry hunger and
cravings and so if you can reach them in
social situations and social situations
you bigger and when you're usually going
out with people that helps absolutely
yeah yeah so in that sense I mean I
recommend that for a lot of people that
they skip breakfast which you could call
a form of enzyme in the fasting yeah
okay alright well Andy I I think that's
about all the questions we have for you
okay thanks for coming on this was I
feel a really good interview if you guys
think so let me know in the comments if
you don't please keep your opinion to
yourself don't forget to Like and
subscribe check out Andy's website it is
written if you speak English it's ripped
body JP and if you're a Japanese speaker
it is athlete's body JP and yeah if you
have any questions for either of us post
them in the comments and and thanks for
coming man thank you very alright and
we'll see you in the next video peace
our guest today is Andy Morgan you'll
learn a lot more about what the [ __ ]
is a creepy
[ __ ] okay
hi I'm we're back with another episode
of Greg knuckles and Andy Morgan on
strength eerie calm she is called 1-866
get jacked for summer and shredded
that's that's the length of a phone
number all right
phone lines are open we're waiting for
your call so what so why would someone
hire a coach rest in peace billy mays
will never forget you know your ear okay
I hate you guys so much this could be
sick all right after a small bit of
tomfoolery we're back for Andy sales pay
that that's British right tom foolery
tom foolery would say yes you winking
Greg is the creepiest thing sure that's
it yeah not bad not bad
it's like if you wanna brood with all
the hopes and dreams of a young puppy
that did not come to fruition in its
long life but it can still sit
gracefully on a couch and observe its
owners going about their day-to-day life
[ __ ] no one's really sad it lived a
happy life alright just to bring you up
to speed on things
Andy's very intimidated by Lindsay
that's it's just really not a good feel
for canines to get into these days we're
gonna catch me ridin dirty tryna catch
me ridin dirty tryna catch me ridin
dirty